مع بدايه صباح العربيه نتابع معكم بدورنا
ملف الانتخابات الامريكيه لكن من زاويه
مختلفه المشاهير ايضا لاعبون في
الانتخابات وبما انه حديث الساعه الى
الماسك صاحب المزاج المتقلب دعا صراحه
الناخبين لدعم المرشحين الجمهوريين ماسك
عاده وغرد قائلا انه منفتح على فكره
التصويت للديمقراطيين مره اخرى في
المستقبل وانه تاريخيا كان مستقلا وسوط
لديمقراطيين لكن ربما ما غير رايه هو
مصلحته الاقتصاديه فقد عبر عن دعمه
للجمهوريين سابقا بعد اقتراح الديمقراطيين
بفرد ضرائب على الملياردات ولا ننسى طبعا
الخلافات العلميه مع رئيس
ليس فقط مصر وهو الذي يقضي به 114 مليون
متابعه على تويتر من يعلن توجهها السياسي
بالفعل تتسارقها اصحاب المال والمشاهير
ممثلين مغنيين الرياضيين قرروا للخراطه
بشكل واضح في المشهد يا سلام الملكي تشير
دراسات لان هناك تاثير كبير للمشاهير ليس
فقط جهه النزول للصناديق الاقتراع بل
لتغيير ارائهم في احيان اخرى واختيار مرشح
بعينه فمثلا وحسب ارقام الانتخابات
التمهيديه لحزب الديمقراطي عام 2008 فان
حماس المذيعه الشهيره اوبرا ونفيلي براك
اوباما حينها منحه نحو مليون صوت اضافي
[موسيقى]
المشاهير لاعبون اساسيون في الانتخابات
الامريكيه كيف يغيرون
اهل السلطه في ازمه ثقه بين السياسيين
التقليديين
وناس من هون
جامعه تبرعات اسكندريه
بحفله تنصيب عنده ليه دجاجه وجايلو وكيتي
باري بيكون عارف شو عم بيعمل يعني عم يجذب
من لا يهتم بالسياسي اليه اضيف الى ذلك
الناس انتخبت
فولدومير زينسكي باكرين ممثل وفكاهي سابق
رونالدو
السياسي والفن والشهره مش شديد وبراي
بيغذوا بعضهم لان بيستفيدوا من بعض
المشاهير بتستفيد من عالم السياسي من حيث
النفوذ
والترستيج اللي ما بيعطيوني بس الفن
والرجال وسيدات السياسي بيستفيدوا تيوصلوا
لشريحه اكبر ويزيدوا اهتمام الاعلام فيهم
[موسيقى]